IAN LAKE: Hello, internet.
We've heard that
you're mad at Joanna.
JOANNA SMITH: Wait, what?
IAN LAKE: Your toolbar
video did not even
cover scrolling gestures.
What's with that?
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Hold on.
I only had two minutes,
and the internet
has the attention span of Dory.
IAN LAKE: Wait, wait.
Don't leave.
It's OK.
This is important.
We'll get through this.
We just need to cover the
whole scrolling, toolbars,
and AppBar thing.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So let's go over
some scrollFlags.
IAN LAKE: Well, it's
not just scrollFlags.
We have to talk about
the whole thing.
JOANNA SMITH: Fun fact.
The AppBar is actually
just the ActionBar
with a fancy new name.
IAN LAKE: Well, it's not
just a fancy new name.
It's actually the anchor
for your whole app.
JOANNA SMITH: If that
were true, don't you
think they would have
called it AnchorBar?
IAN LAKE: Eh,
AnchorBar's a silly name.
And the Android SDK has
nothing silly in it.
JOANNA SMITH: Of course not.
But anyway, you can
customize your AppBar
if you choose to use
a toolbar instead
of the standard
framework choice.
Thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: You're welcome.
JOANNA SMITH: Like I
explained in my DevByte.
IAN LAKE: It's really good.
You should go watch it.
JOANNA SMITH: Aw, thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: But it doesn't
actually answer the question.
Where's the scrolling magic?
JOANNA SMITH: Well, it's an
AppBar layout, of course.
But you're right.
I still haven't talked
about scrolling gestures.
IAN LAKE: You're right.
You should probably
talk about it.
It's a big deal.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So I was just about to.
[SIGHS]
So you want scrolling
gestures in your app
to help you put content first
in a pretty fantastic way
by hiding the
chrome of your app.
Right.
OK.
So when you decide to
use an AppBar toolbar,
you'll need three things.
The first is a
CoordinatorLayout on the top.
Thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: You're welcome.
JOANNA SMITH: And then
you need an AppBar layout
containing the toolbar.
Thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: You're welcome.
JOANNA SMITH: And
finally, you want
your main scrollable content,
such as our RecyclerView.
Thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: You're welcome.
JOANNA SMITH: Now, if you forget
to specify the layout behavior
attribute, your app is going to
go all cattywampus and overlap.
So don't forget it.
And then finally, the
layout scrollFlags attribute
is the magic that'll make it go.
IAN LAKE: Cattywampus?
Is that really a word?
I'm--
JOANNA SMITH: Yes,
IAN LAKE: --not seeing it.
JOANNA SMITH: Well,
if it wasn't a word,
I would not have said it.
IAN LAKE: I believe her.
So what do these scrollFlags
actually do for your app?
JOANNA SMITH: Well,
so values like scroll
indicate that the whole thing
will scroll off the screen.
And then enterAlways
indicates that it'll overturn,
as soon as you scroll back.
IAN LAKE: Wow.
A quick return pattern.
It's actually a
very common pattern.
JOANNA SMITH: Precisely.
So hopefully, that helped
clear up some of the-- thanks--
scrolling magic for all
of you eager developers.
Thanks, Ian.
IAN LAKE: No problem.
JOANNA SMITH: And
so go out there
and build better apps already.
Stop.
IAN LAKE: Good job.
JOANNA SMITH: Build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]